okay in this video playing super
saiyajin I only recently have played him
chat very complicated game in them in
the NIMS oh where I had white so the
storm reverse colors and in the bogo
Indian let's see okay he's going for
Bishop g5 yeah I must take care of the
e3 threat this is why I need to take a
three traps the bishop okay yeah this is
some a very common part structure in
this line black will put the bishop back
on c5 and often play 95 g6 getting some
pieces in the direction of the Kings
side it's quite unremarkable that's that
black iridium has some attacking chances
at times really getting at the king okay
Paul age 6 can always play and okay I
guess 95 should be it should be alright
this sum is also taking c4 night b3 is
not possible anymore now I can play
Knight a form but then I can go all the
way back to a seven-night b5 should be
eight even this is not a problem does
this has been played in it again Shiro
against him international masters oil in
the german bundesliga some years ago
this idea at least with bishop be aid
and it turned out that black was
excellent
factor sheriff lost the game rather
rather clearly as white against the 2500
player okay it's not exactly the same
position but it's quite close should I
send the night back now hmm yeah there
should be six on Knight b6 it's
important that c5 I always have DD 5 so
this is not a problem at all
can always go to d4 I cannot easily
easily develop my bishop here that's a
problem yeah I wonder wonder if I could
do this yam it's fairly untypical for
this structure night situ I wanted to
play Bishop f5 but then he has an idea
form yeah this basically means that a 94
was wasn't leading anywhere okay maybe I
can play Bishop d7 here but should be
726 very complicated position and not
not really clear at least i am not i'm
not sure what what the assessment is why
should probably be slightly better but
but it's not they're not easy yeah i try
to place these six after all as I always
got might be six okay I don't mind if
you place 94 it takes this Bishop the
bishop on c6 is of course a problem with
in terms of the behave bishop but all
this I don't think is a long-term
mission okay
yeah g7 la is just the ticking g7 very
simple
95 maybe 95 I don't really think f4 it's
something that white wants to do with an
ID EG for coming okay now i can earn
return here okay now i need some sort of
counter play here
yeah that's it's impossible to go
without c64 ever study it's got this
this bloody Knight b6 move
yeah maybe I need to do it anyway go
look a six as strange as it looks I'm
somewhat down long time I'm not sure
about the position I mean white has the
space advantage but I'm not totally sure
this this kind of g3 h4 is also not
ideal for him yar Knight b6 basics I
hope this is okay I didn't see anything
else I mean I cannot play with with the
b8 Bishop forever normally it is not a
big issue that it goes back because you
can play c6 and get it back into the
game but yeah I never never really was
confident yeah exchange seconds not not
really on I think yeah Bishop e7 mmm
well that's lots of stuff on the
queenside
hmm now I just saw it I had except you
I'm already five of the night now
somewhat exposed okay you have at least
gotten might only be 684 this is not not
perfect maybe you can okay then if I've
I see but I can take a three it's not
it's maybe not totally clear take care
to take see one or just recapture and
keep the Queen's on and don't know I get
c1 anyway yeah my rook here is the real
problem on a six try to go to check on
v3 here
rookie to it's not easy to play this
position it's just a very tricky I'm
certainly worse but i'm not i'm not
totally sure how how goes
microphone should see two first I have
absolutely no time well check I really
didn't didn't recognize that
like it's totally winning now but it's
always gently important with the time
Black forfeits anti yeah I did it cost
me too much time to play the server this
this very complicated little game so I
was down on the clock yeah probably
around here widest also winning but he
never he really couldn't finish me off
and it was right here it's totally
unclear this position I've got two
points and the rook for 2 minor pieces
and it's really a really complicated
well here night f2 is even good for
black the ID was the problem was the
time really oh yeah I can I can take I
can take c3f to lv 6 totally winning
okay yeah this actually would have been
been a chance even in with this time
okay I was this was looking good so I
played it not really looking group d
three wins and so Anya and by now he had
to completely lost the threat and I'm
also currently winning in the final
position it's just a huge difference if
you play a check out dated time
controller with increment with
incrementer those games get get finished
by chess I'm not by by 15 seconds on the
clock oh yeah it was just a bit too
complicated here for me to spend spend
too much time around here why does
certainly better but it was difficult to
play okay thanks for watching